are you a young graduate who is applying
for the first job are you a young
professional who is looking to
transition careers surely one thing that
will be very important to succeed is a
strong cv when i applied to the
consulting firm mckinsey back in the
days i faced the same challenge so in
this video i want to share some of my
knowledge by reviewing your cvs so a
couple of days ago on my instagram i
asked you to submit some cvs to me for
me to potentially review them if you
want to have your cv included the
potential future videos like this follow
me on instagram this is where i most
likely will talk about this again before
we start diving into the cvs a couple of
preliminary remarks first of all all of
these things are of course just my
humble opinions my humble experiences
surely the topic of how a strong cv
looks like is a topic for many people
have many differing opinions on but feel
free to challenge me also in the
comments if you have another view on any
of the points that i'm raising so
welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel firm learning my name is
heinrich on my channel i want to help
you to become successful in the first
years of your career in addition also
for both the cv and the cover letter
template for you as a download these
were the very same templates that i used
myself when i successfully applied to
the consulting for mckinsey back in the
days you'll find a link to them in the
video description so feel free to check
them out so let's start looking at this
first cd here and let's just go by a
very first impression so just looking at
this how does this seem does this seem
professional and good or not and i'd say
this is not very bad i mean it's not not
terrible but there's surely some things
that you could improve so let's look
just at a couple of things that i think
are not really on point not really ideal
here and first let's start with some
alignment points so i'm just zooming in
here let's go up here we see that here
all kinds of different levels are used
when things start right so here you have
a level of text where this level it
starts this here is a bit indented
further to the right this line here is
even a bit further left than this stuff
this here is even further left so you
see all different types of layout levels
where elements start all right next
let's talk a bit more about the content
for instance about an introductory text
like this so actually many cvs that i
received are saw people including a
little intro text in the beginning and
here i'm not saying this is a deal break
how this alone will get you rejected but
let's just try to put ourselves into the
shoes of a person who reads cvs you will
have a big stack of cvs a big stack of
paper on your desk you will just go one
after the other will try to skim the cv
for some keywords for the key things
that you did where did you work where
did you study what are your grades what
are your responsibilities i would argue
that these people will not even care to
bother to start reading a big paragraph
of text like this so max is a strategy
and consulting manager and is aligned to
the company capital markets practice he
has a professional understanding of the
financial sector blah blah blah blah
blah i mean these are things that you
will directly see if you read it right
you hear a senior consultant what did
you do security settlement okay got it
right so no need for any explanations
like this next let's talk about a
picture here in the top right this is
also a question that i get quite
frequently so are you supposed to
include a picture in the cv or not and
yeah i'd say it really depends probably
most on the region where you apply to so
i'd argue more the anglo-saxon countries
the uk also the u.s and so on i'd say
it's rather unusual to include it for of
course discrimination reasons you don't
want cvs to be assessed based on the
looks of a person for instance in
countries like germany i would claim
that it is still very common to have a
picture on your cv so probably i would
also still do it in a country like
germany though if you apply for instance
via an online form often that online
forms have specific fields where you can
upload a picture so if you did already
upload a picture to such a form then i'd
say you also don't need the picture on
the cv personally on my standard cv i
don't have a picture included of course
with the nice one page format that i
would recommend you to use in general a
picture takes a lot of space often
doesn't integrate that nicely in the
layout so if you can i probably try to
get away with not including it on the
suv but in some reasons it's surely not
a problem next let's talk about there's
a very general layout here of this cv
where you have here the key content side
on the left and then this additional bar
here on the right and actually several
cvs that you sent me had variations of
this layout and my humble perspective on
this is that i would probably rather not
go for these layouts so surely if you
apply to a marketing agency or maybe
another very creative job sure be
creative do some fancy maybe also build
unorthodox stuff on your severe trust
there it's okay but especially if you
apply to more conservative industries
like consulting or like banking surely
you will not get invited to an interview
because of the way how you layouted your
cv this is just not the way of thinking
about this the best case scenario is the
people who just not care that you use
the layout like this but of course the
worst case scenario is that this will
rub people the wrong way people might
feel like ah maybe you didn't do your
research you didn't know how a typical
siri layout for these industries look
like and surely this is not the
impression that you want to leave and
i'd argue also from a functional
perspective layouts like this are not
very effective let's just see how much
space is wasted here with the personal
info the personal info you can usually
include just in one line in the very
header of your one page cv you will
later see a couple of other examples of
people did that and same thing here for
the languages i mean this takes so much
space you can just write this in one
simple line and let's not even get me
started here on all these dots to
indicate your language proficiency
because indeed what we do see is that
actually the font size here of the body
of the cv is very small this is a very
small font size and yes i get that on
one page of cvs often you have lots of
text and often the font size cannot be
too large but this is very small right
and you would have all these other
opportunities to make more space for the
text increase the font size and also in
general at least in the body of your cv
i would recommend you to always use the
same font size it always looks a bit
unclean not very polished if you have
here tags with a larger font size then
here it gets smaller this is larger
again that doesn't just look very clean
very polished so rather go for the same
font size whenever possible let's move
to the second cv and by the way i will
try on the different cvs to highlight
different things right so only because i
don't point out again the things that i
may be pointed out on prior cvs of
course they're still very much so true
but let's just continue here and very
first impression again maybe think about
this for yourself right what is the very
first impression that you have and i'd
say it's rather good i like it i think
it's very clear very well organized the
layout seems nice and clean in principle
i like it here we also see some of these
a bit more modern layout elements like
these icons here to indicate your
address the phone and so on this blue
border around your picture this light
gray or these blue bars here to indicate
a new subsection i mean i don't know so
surely this won't get you rejected
personally i also think it looks good
here still probably myself if i would
write a cv for me i would still go for
the very conservative style without all
these things included the thing that
probably bothers me most is just the
length this is just a lot of content two
full pages let's also forget that this
person is still a student and i know
that the general rule is that up to two
pages is okay i think more than two
pages is really bad you should not do it
but i would still recommend you to go
for the one pager layout every single cv
out there you can condense to one pager
layout even if you have 30 40 years of
work experience it's always possible to
bring it to one page of course what this
means is that you need to focus you
maybe need to cut out some things which
are not the strongest things you want to
talk about or really reduce them to a
minimum but i trust that everybody
already was in a position to review cvs
it's almost much nicer to have one page
just instead of always needing to go
back and forth across different pages
and also one page in general helps you
much more to really focus on your
awesomeness so ideally the impression
that you want to create is that someone
reads your cv and every single line
right every single line just reads wow
this is crazy impressive impressive
awesome never seen this this is
incredible but if you drag out the
content over two pages usually you don't
have enough things to really fill it
with that much awesomeness then the
awesome points really just get lost the
more mediocre points and this is just
not the first impression that you want
to give so let's just look at that what
are the things that maybe you would want
to cut out that maybe you don't want to
focus on that much and if you read it
surely the big household names like bmw
alliance and so on these surely are the
things you do want to focus on but then
you also read things like nera dynamics
a b c a strategy consultants and so on
and if as a student you already have
these very strong internships at bmw
alliance and so on do you think someone
would really care that you worked at
nera dynamics or ca strategy consultants
and again don't want to come off here as
condescending i just don't know these
firms maybe these are very great firms
some hidden champions in a very niche
but i'd argue the general hr content
will just not know them and just also
one thing to understand is that you
don't need to list every single work
experience every single internship that
you ever completed throughout your life
so probably at the point when i applied
to mckinsey at the end of my bachelor
likely half of the internships i ever
did i didn't even list any more on my cv
because i just replaced them by stronger
points by stronger stations at the point
in time and the other thing that i
always find a little bit weird when i
read this especially on a student cv are
things like being an external consultant
of course this is always a little bit
weird but you're a student why would a
big company engage you as an external
consultant what type of experience was
that so this always leaves some question
marks if then you scroll down i think
the explanation is that this person
worked at academy consult i just
happened to know that organization
because they are from munich they are a
student-based consulting firm so this of
course great great and relevant
experience but then maybe just to
condense it a little bit you might be
able to take these external consulting
positions and then rather list them here
for instance within the academy consult
position just to make this a little bit
more intuitive how exactly that went and
this will help you to save some space
and also help the reader of this cv just
in a more intuitive way understand what
exactly happened there what exactly did
you do here following the idea of saving
space also things like language skills
computer skills hobbies these are things
that you can just very shortly write on
one line if you're looking for some
inspiration on that in the cv template
that i will offer you as a download in
the video description you can see
exactly how i did it and there and then
there's also this thing here in the end
with the location the date and the
signature i know that many people will
tell you that you need to include it at
least in germany it's very customary to
do so to be honest in all the
applications that i wrote i never
included it i always didn't see the
point of doing that it always felt like
a waste of space to me i would rather
maybe sign the cover letter if you want
to sign something so judge this for
yourself whether you want to include it
or not for me it was never a problem to
leave it out but i do know that some
people feel like it needs to be included
on every cv so trust you will decide
what's right for you as a last point
let's talk about the bullets that you
write and we will on a later cv probably
talk a little bit more about how to
write bullets but just one thing i want
to point your attention to what i would
in general always avoid is writing
things like supporting something this
sounds very weak right it's really
difficult to understand what you really
did there what your impact was what your
contribution was also things like
developing of market and business field
strategies here on top i mean these
things are so vague they really fail to
highlight what your experiences really
are what the impact was that you created
for that organization but let's deep
dive into considerations like this a bit
more in the future so let's look at the
next cv and here again first impression
what do we think about this i think
what's very clear just first sight that
this cv is far too long i mean this is
frankly just unacceptable you cannot
make a cv with six pages really two
pages should be the absolute maximum i
would recommend you to only work with
one page but six pages is just not okay
so let's just see what this person did
here and here first of all let's look at
the alignment i mean here again the
bullets start to the right then further
down it starts here to the left and then
if we go down we see things like this
for instance whether suddenly something
starts further to the right i mean this
is surely not okay this is not what i
would recommend you to do then some
other small sloppy things in the
formatting let's notice how here this
longer dash is used i believe it's
called an m dash whereas here a shorter
dash and n dash as i believe it's called
is used these are just sloppy small
things in the formatting then of course
you should rather avoid next let's talk
about the professional experience and
here first let's talk also about the
order of the sections so i'd say the
general recommended way is that as long
as you are a student you start your cv
after the personal details with the
education section because surely this is
the focus for you as a student but as
soon as you are a professional a working
professional who moves out of university
i'd say it's customary then to move up
the professional experience section and
then only afterwards show the education
section because surely this will usually
be what will be more relevant to the
person reading the cv what you should
definitely avoid is writing about these
experiences like you would write a
paragraph in a book so just full
sentences full paragraph of text it's
just really difficult just to quickly
read over this skim through it and just
in a straightforward way get the most
important pieces of information out of
it it really forces the people to read
through all of this and this even
combined with the fact that the cv in
itself is already so long it's just so
annoying just such a hassle for the
person looking at that i promise you the
people will get annoyed that we'll need
to read this also the formatting this of
course is just not really nice you know
having a page break in the middle of
such a position let's further move down
here we now see all the courses that
this person completed i mean it's surely
great that the person did that many
things i mean you're frankly not sure
what all of this is this looks like
university courses surely you don't need
to list all the courses that you
attended at university on your cv this
just creates the impression that you're
not able to distinguish the things that
really matter from the things that maybe
don't matter that much so again same
thing here with awards and the same with
also published materials so as long as
you apply for an academic job i'd argue
a publication list does not need to be
part of the cv if you want to include it
i would rather maybe in your awards and
honor section or your other
qualification section i just include one
line and really just highlight the key
achievements here maybe that you publish
an article in an a plus or in an a
journal right things like that surely
are impressive but hey come on i mean
let's not write about newspaper articles
that you wrote or your undergraduate
theaters this is surely not what what
should be relevant here for your cv so
enough about that let's move to the next
cv so what i like is that it is on a one
pager format but i think here the first
impression just without really looking
at it the first impression is that
somehow this looks a little bit messy
and a bit unusual right so let's just
look into that what do we see here i
mean first of all just the top section
i'd argue that you can include your
personal details in an even more space
effective way as has been done here
again feel free to check out the cv
template that i offer you as a download
in the video description also things
like a linkedin profile i'd say is not
really needed i mean surely all the
infos that you have on your linkedin you
will likely also have in here also this
very dark black bars here at the top i
mean this looks just very dominant this
dark black just a bit unusual also not
something that i would include and also
summary sentences like this here on top
we already discussed for the first cv so
let's continue looking at this and one
thing that comes to mind is that even
though this is a one pager there's still
lots of wide space so the impression
that this summer creates is that even
though you only had one page you were
not even able to fill all this page with
good and relevant content then if you
continue looking at that you can see
that here just from the language and
skills section this takes almost half of
the page i mean this is a section that
probably just in a very small section in
the bottom you will talk about so for
instance a section that i will flash out
much more is the academic education
section so for instance what are your
majors what are the main subjects that
you're focusing on what is your gpa what
are maybe some other academic leadership
positions that you have so surely these
are things i talk about and i'd say here
in the work experience there are a
couple of things in here which are a
little bit weird i mean what are these
numbers here two and one i'm just not
really getting it also here the
formatting of these bullets is a little
bit weird here i mean this should surely
be indented here also to the level of
the right and i just come back to the
point of how you ride bullets so as i
already hinted before i would always
stress on the impact and the results
that you created for the company so
instead of writing automation of process
with efficiency gains and risk reduction
i would rather always try to quantify it
right so how did you implement these
efficiency gains to what measurable
results did this really lead for the
company the key basic idea is that
whenever possible whenever it makes
sense you should include a number in the
bullets of your cv just to make them
tangible make them graspable help
everyone understand the impact that you
had what i do like is what the person
wrote here below with the volunteer
coordinator so talking about
coordinating a team of 40 volunteers in
a project i think this is great really
talking about the leadership that you
had how large the team was that you led
of course here it would have been great
to also focus a bit more again on the
impact that you had in your volunteering
so what was the good that you created
for your community for the organization
here talk about that as well because
surely that was your goal for
volunteering after all last but not
least let's look at one more and again
let's start with first impression here
and i'd argue that likely this for me
gives the strongest first impression
this is most closely to the layout that
usually you can expect when applying to
consulting to banking to more
conservative professional services
industries like that so what you can see
here is a nice and clean one-pager cv
you see how the name and the personal
details really only takes minimum space
in the header of the cv this is the
classical way of doing it this logo to
the left i'm not really understanding
what exactly that is looks like maybe
the logo of the university again maybe
i'm just not getting the meaning i'd say
probably not something that you need to
include but i'd say the overall layout
the structure of the cv is very good and
clean so you start with education
professional experiences leadership and
awards volunteer experience very good
very clear very well done the one thing
that maybe is a little bit unorthodox
just with these a bit more like modern
design elements are these points that
were included here but why not i mean
again surely this won't be a problem one
little i guess error is here the spacing
between the points right so here
apparently a space is missing whereas
here we have spaces here again the space
is missing here again a space is missing
similar thing here also with the dashes
so here there are spaces between the
dashes here there are no spaces between
the dashes here again inconsistencies
with the m and n dashes so the longer
and the shorter dash again maybe i'm
just too super critical about these
things but these are things when i look
at cvs for whatever reason they just
directly jump in my eye i just cannot
help but notice these things and of
course the underlying reasoning why
these things maybe do matter is that if
you work for instance a professional
services you create documents for your
clients you will for sure get feedback
on points like this right so if in your
client documents you just mess up only
these small layout inconsistencies i
mean these are things that you will get
feedback on from a project lead for your
team lead and so on and of course the
logic is that you know this is your cv
so this is a document where you surely
invested lots of time to really get it
right to the smallest amount of detail
right and the impression of course of
this creates is that maybe you lack the
attention of detail and if you cannot
even get such a document right how are
you expected to get these things right
if it's already you know late at night
you're under lots of pressure in a short
amount of time you need to create a
significant amount of documents i mean
this is just the reasoning that an hr
professional might have in his or her
head when just looking at things like
that and then making comments on that
but overall i must say i do like it also
notice here how the bullets are written
for instance this person writes
increased
asset product sales by 50 percent by
revitalizing distributor portfolio and
adding to customer base and so on so
forth so you really focus on the impact
here so the next one contributed towards
annual saving of over 80 000 euro
brought in something that reduced opex
cost by 12 saving 50 000 euro and so on
and so forth so really always pushing
for the measurable impact this is the
style that you want to go for just my
little other layout stylus i mean first
of all i really like this idea of
bolding things like that i think this
really helps guide the eye to the most
important words to the things that you
really want to focus on but then i would
argue if you do this try to have that
one bolded thing in all of the bullet
points so for instance here is also
actually quite big bullet point without
any boarded elements here i would also
argue that i think two lines of text for
one bullet usually are enough so it
would rather condense a bullet of three
lines but further to two lines this just
looks a little bit cleaner also if then
all the other bullets are two lines as
we have it here that if you have
suddenly a bullet of three lines this
somehow sticks out probably not really
necessary rather cut it down and then of
course if you do have an icb like that
with all this content probably what i
would think about whether you wouldn't
want to give a little bit more space to
the volunteering experience i mean this
can be a little nice additional touch on
what you did makes you seem to be a bit
more of a rounded character right not a
person who just lives for a cv not only
a person who looks for his or her
education gpa and work experience so if
you are writing for social causes i
trust you raise money maybe right for a
social course so why don't talk about
that how much money you raised what your
leadership position was and bringing
this to life making sure that this
happened last but not least just because
we haven't talked about it in that much
detail i'd argue probably most regions
it's very customary to in your education
section when you talk about your degrees
that you also include your gpa again i
understand that university systems are a
bit different but if you received any
type of numeric gpa i would recommend
you to also include it here on the cv
sometimes people ask me where my gpa
wasn't that strong should i still
include it even if it wasn't that strong
and i'd say yes because at least myself
usually whenever i see a cv without gpa
i just assume that the person doesn't
have such a great gpa right because
otherwise the person would show it on
the cv and then it's always just an
annoyance to needing to look at the
university transcripts maybe that the
person hopefully then attached just look
through all the documents to pull out
the gpas that the person actually has
this is just annoying a waste of time be
transparent include them and of course
ideally what always also helps and you
probably would only include it if really
these numbers are good but if you have a
good also percentage rank so if you can
show that you are part of the top five
top 10 maybe top 15 percent of your
class i would surely include this here
in the cv as well because of course this
helps also the hr professional just to
understand and contextualize the gpa a
little bit better especially maybe if
you're applying from university that
maybe isn't one of the big target
schools where it's a bit less clear on
what the gpa really means whether this
is a good result or not so do you have
any additional tips to share on how to
ride a strong cv so just leave a comment
in the comment section trust you would
all benefit from that if you took any
value out of this video at all please
destroy the like button for the youtube
algorithm and also hit subscribe and
turn on the notification bell to stay up
to date on all my content thank you to
all the members of from learning for
supporting the channel this is very much
appreciated my name is simon i have
these videos every single weekend on
saturdays see you again next week until
then all the best to you and bye